[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
happy sunday the kansas city chiefs are
hosting their
third consecutive afc championship game
and the only place
that feels more like home is right here
with the squad welcome to the squad ride
live in the bleach report app presented
by draftkings my name is cavi richards
our betting expert in his is in the
middle that's kelly michelle stewart
and the only way to get on to the power
rankings is to tap
in with greg ivory also please say the
please
please we bet anytime touchdowns on this
show and we're 14 and five so salute
to aaron jones and the short game legend
oscar 19 parkinson
for the pick much appreciated homie we
love that
uh programming note tomorrow we are back
in the app
for a special edition of our new show
the br drop zone
gotta tap in with us tomorrow 6 p.m
eastern on monday
we have uh we'll be dropping exclusive
giraffe kings
super bowl props we'll have special
guesses our special guests
and greg ivory will be extra generous
like it's christmas in january
gabby you know i'm going to be you know
i'm going to be generous
tomorrow i'm giving out
a ps5 uh
1500 i need 1500 in the comments right
now
1500 dk dollars
and as always always always
i'm giving out those hoodies man giving
out those hoodies
we asked you on social earlier this week
who is a lock to score a touchdown
in championship weekend four teams left
eight superstars on the board let's take
a look at the graphic
interesting to note tyrique hill has
never scored a touchdown against the
bills
maybe he will today on the other side of
the ball staphon diggs the score
back it scored a touchdown in
back-to-back games we have a great list
and we have a great show
up ahead we have five new legendary
videos to show you and one of them is
going to be our
conference championship squad ride so
let's begin
our first pitch comes from mark marriage
who knows the secret life of pets
oh he wanted mike evans dude
you're hesitating you can't hesitate in
this business buzz
oh there goes that man
according to my notes that hamster is
number two in the power rankings in
bubble
soccer so well done uh our next pitch
comes from austin arsenau who went deep
into the toy box
so i've been on a cold streak lately so
i figured i'm gonna let my dog pick the
anytime touchdown score this weekend
let's see who he's got
mike evans mike evans any time touchdown
scorer this weekend
let's go like i said
austin went deep into the toy box so our
first matchup alan lazard
versus mike evans g-money what'd you
think of the creativity of these videos
cavi that hamster uh he has some wheels
he was moving i might need him on my
fantasy team next year
uh alan lazard huh i really don't know
about the pick but let's move on
to the other uh video because cabbie um
that game is probably older than me
absolutely
that game is probably older than me but
uh i i kind of like the pick i kind of
like to pick my guy mike
evans uh yeah one reception for three
yards and he scored a td
uh i don't know kelly i'm i'm i'm torn i
i don't know you know better you know
value you know numbers talk to us
lazard evans which way are you leaning
so we've already talked about this on
the show week after week greg
when draftkings gives us an odds boost
of three to one
why would i want to bet a guy that's
plus 135 or a guy that's plus 210
that being said i like lazard to score a
touchdown kathy now we're talking about
this as we're prepping
for another show i think this wide
receiver three has gonna move into the
wide receiver two spot here
i do think he's gonna get some targets
davonte adams is gonna be double team
today
so while i don't want to use this for
the oz boost i think he's worth a little
sprinkle
today to score a touchdown on the flip
side
mike evans we know he's had some injury
issues this year
he appears to be fully healthy but to be
honest
i want neither these guys to score
touchdown i have the under in this game
under 53 and a half
from this morning i just gave it out on
twitter so
i hope neither of them score a touchdown
again under someone's gonna score a
touchdown here it's going to be alan
lazard
wow wow wow kelly
she's rocking without luna's arch score
touchdown wow but let me get into these
comments
kelly cabbie you guys know what this is
this is the handy dandy
ipad and i got dandy ipad saying that
hamster is faster than brady
that might be a fact shouts out to you
you're walking away
with the hoodie uh i got sick
oreos saying both these options lose
next round regardless of the contender
wow bro that is bad vibes that is bad
bops no hoodie
no hoodie there you're lying though greg
true but those are bad guys being honest
let me get back into the comments hold
on i got one more for you cabbie
i got one more for you uh
they they as cappy said earlier this is
jimmy sheen
evans is getting locked down take lazard
uh i i one more i'm
one more and i'm going to pick the
winner all right kevin you ready here we
go i'm ready baby
here we go evans we're going we're
we're rocking with evans we're right now
with mike evans okay
we're rocking with evan all right well
uh shout out to austin arsenault
the dot the dog legend and uh maybe jair
alexander
won't repeat what he did in week six
which was clamp mike evans we'll see
let's move on to round two well done sir
our next pitch comes from
louis de castro which players make it
bank for us this week homie
all right nfc conference championship
game aaron jones anytime touchdown score
winners only please you heard it here
the lock
yes his lady's back all that video
needed wasn't
all right all right all right but can't
have everything we asked for
g money what'd you think of the cowboy
legend and his pick with
erin jones cabbie i love the winners
only
i love love love the please
i love the special guests i didn't even
know she was there shouts out to her
they made it through they made it but
what but all i want to know is
where's buzz lightyear at my guy got the
woody hat on
not rocking it like come on i this
where's the fashion police where is the
fashion police greg i think i have one
just like that in my closet can you not
i mean it might yeah it doesn't look
good on him i'm sorry i'm so
it does not look good let's talk about
the pick though aaron jones we wrote him
last week abby
we wrote him last week and i've been
saying it i've been saying it
although the packers got the
three-headed monsters you know how they
they feed their backs it's three of them
when they get inside the five
i like my chances with aaron jones we
got it last week
i i i can see it happening again it's
plus money
i mean i'm kind of sold but
but but kelly you know numbers
you know value and i know you got to
take on the game
so talk to us which way are you leaning
aaron jones should we ride
well i mentioned i was already on the
under but somebody's going to score a
touchdown today i mean this one's in the
50s
obviously i'm just hoping for a few more
field goals than touchdowns but greg you
nailed it
when they get within basically under the
10 yard line
guess who's getting the rock aaron jones
every single time
when they're running a play that's not
a little deep into the end zone to
devonta adams
aaron jones is getting the ball i like
it here i know that he's really started
to become
less and less of a value i mean man when
we started this year aaron jones was
almost two to one now he's just plus 100
even money that's okay though i think if
i have to choose between the two this
one's an
easy pick i like aaron jones caddy kelly
i'm back into the comments
i got greg my guy the goat he's spamming
us saying the same thing brother that is
not how you win a hoodie
that is not we need takes we don't need
you to repeat the same comment
anyway i'm back into the i'm back into
the comments
uh i got tk244 says aaron jones [ __ ]
i've
been averaging a honey not a hundred
cabbie
a honey a game shouts out to you tk
you know that's how we you know that's
how we vibe man it's hunnid's over here
uh i got uh ben benson k619 he gave me a
gift aaron jones gift
he gave me the gift cabbie uh shouts out
to you ben you're walking away with a
hoodie
i got one more cabbie one more one more
uh sick sick is back into the comments
sick is back into the comments i think i
gave him a hoodie earlier but he's
rocking with aaron jones finn sanders he
says aaron jones is double money locked
all right cabbie it's apparent
oh it sounds like it it's a pair we're
riding with
we are riding with aaron jones
to move on to the next round okay salute
to aaron jones who was our squad ride
last week he's moving on to round two
along with the cowboy legend
there are two more opponents left let's
get it round three begins our next pitch
comes from eminem in who went into the
80s to discramble the code
travis kelsey anytime touchdown score
lock it in
yo that was impressive i'm so glad the
jigsaw puzzle was travis kelsey and not
jigsaw from the saw movies
because i still have nightmares don't
no talk about bad vibes those are those
aren't bad vibes it's just when i saw
the jigsaw i just figured
you know that's the first thing that
came to mind anyway g money what'd you
think of the creativity from mim
or eminem i am this week and the travis
kelsey pig
i think the chiefs are going to be able
to put the pieces together
and travis kelsey
is going to get in the end zone you guys
see what i did there yeah
well good work you guys see what i did
there
let's talk about travis kelsey cabbie
let's talk about a five straight games
with a touchdown seven
catches per game in those games and the
chiefs won
11 straight he said that minus 125 and
you know what we do here
we boost that up to plus 300. i'm loving
that i
am absolutely loving the travis kelsey
play uh
he has to have a big game today i cannot
wait for that bill's
uh chiefs game i honestly can't wait i
cannot wait
but uh kelly talk to us talk to us we
got aaron jones we got travis kelsey
which way are you leaning which way
should we lead
we'll get into the the chief's bills
game for my best bet
here at the end of the show a teaser a
little
a little bit of a teaser so i don't want
to give away too much travis kelsey i
wish this said tyreek hill because that
would be a no-brainer to me
look we all know the status of patrick
mahomes is a go
but i have my concerns i i with travis
kelsey here i do think he's basically
oh a big body wide receiver if i have to
pick here i'll go with kelsey minus 125.
i think it like he said in the the
puzzle plus three soon to be plus 300
okay i'll take it i like that from
eminem i am
hey there the comments hey caveat
the comments is that man look they got
travis kelsey hitting the quan
uh that's the og dance
they got travis kelsey uh talking to the
ref
in the comments with the gifts travis
kelsey with the refs
you see travis kelsey at the bottom as
well hey caviar it's a runaway it's a
run let me give away some hoodies let me
give away some hoodies uh
i got i am medina 1120
uh shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh
i got uh ethan krupa
ethan krupa shouts out to you bro you're
walking away with a hoodie
wade zero eight two one you're walking
away cabbie it's apparent
i mean if you just look at the comments
it's all travis kelsey so i don't even
really have to say anything i'm just
giving away hoodies at this point
i think you're gonna cut me off so i'll
just say we're moving on
to the next round with travis kelsey and
the
jigsaw legend excellent one quick you
know all the
the kansas city starters have won 11
straight in a row that that team is on
fire
uh so a salute to eminem i am who moves
on to the final round
with travis kelsey this next matchup
decides
our champion our conference championship
squad ride
so let's get it our final pitch comes
from the old nick legend
riley riley sorbo and one of his
teammates at the farm who you got
oh yeah all right we got
devonta adams travis kelsey
let's see which one we got squadron i
think i'm ready guys
get one
looks like devonte adams lock it in
somebody needs to sign that cat to a
10-day contract in the nba do you see
the
burp on that little guy my guy got up
you know what i think this is the first
time we've seen
riley's face and i didn't know he looks
like a logic that's
it's a good look i love the br hoodie by
the way g muddy what'd you think
of the video and the pick devonta adams
cabbie you know what the kids call that
nowadays
what's that bunnies they call those
bunnies
i need bunnies in the comments i need
bunnies in the comments right now
i'm giving away hoodies if i see bunnies
in the comments because the cat
got the bunnies now let's talk about the
pick
let's talk about the pick devonte adams
minus
182. i don't know about this one guys
what do you mean
i just i i don't know i just don't know
how i feel about this one
kelly uh i know devonte has been
been balling yeah he's scored five
touchdowns in his last three games
the packers are the highest scoring
offense and i i i get all of that but
this is the
it's the championship game i just don't
know kelly talk to me win me over
comments win me over should we ride with
devonta talk to me kelly kelsey
adams greg i really don't want
devonta adams to score a touchdown here
i want this to be an easy under i want
this to be like a 21
17 type game where i don't even have to
sweat it
but this one is a no-brainer devonte
adams showed us
last week against one of the best
defensive backs in the league
that he still should be in contention
for being one of the top
wide receivers this is aaron rodgers
security blanket and you know who else's
security blanket is
he's my security blanket this dude is
making me
money you know why if we just bet this
dude to score a touchdown
any time this year we would be
so rich i wouldn't even be here i'd be
on an island right now
not doing a show with you guys devonte
adams this one's too easy
this dude is scoring a touchdown today
no matter what
get in the comments tell greg what you
think should we ride with all world
devante adams our security blanket
or moon base eights travis kelsey
there are three certainties that i have
in life death
taxes and kelly stewart is going to fade
the public at
all times there are exceptions to the
rule
which happens maybe once or twice in the
football season
so kelly stewart please give the people
your best bet
in a conference championship weekend
kathy i know that it always appears that
i want to fade the public i just think
that we're just so
different in our logic i don't mean for
it to be that way but yes the public
team of the week is the buffalo bills
they are getting love hand over fist and
i understand it's because
of the uncertainty all week long with
patrick mahomes but we knew he was going
to be a go
it's the conference championship game
now i've been against the bills the last
couple of weeks
i got the cash with the colts they were
able to keep it close and almost sprung
the upset
last weekend lamar jackson threw a pick
six when they were going in to score a
touchdown
it is what it is but let me tell you
this the buffalo bills
are getting out gained every week and
eventually that's going to catch up with
them you know when it catches up with
them
this week in kansas city that stadium is
only gonna have
ten thousand fans but that ten thousand
fans is going
to be like a full stadium that place is
going to be rocking
and rolling the chiefs is my best bet i
did lay three
make sure that you get the best price
here three
and if you don't sometimes it's better a
little bit on the money line i know you
can get anywhere from minus 165 to 170.
so actually took
half of my bet bet chiefs minus three
the other half of my bet
chief's money line because we know what
has been the chiefs this last 10 weeks
that's right they have not covered a
game and they have made their betters
lives
really miserable chiefs win and cover
today
for us at home all right the uh
the first win in kansas city's 10 game
win streak
came back in week six against the
buffalo bills
jump on draftkings lock in kc minus six
or sprinkle on the money line
as kelly has done both if you want to
rock with our mvp kelly stewart
greg i know the comment section section
is buzzing i'm sure there are even more
gifs in there uh for you to to look at
hundreds of takes
hundreds of opinions you have the answer
to the question who are we riding with
devonta adams or travis kelsey gabby
this is this is the handy dandy pretty
sure you know that i'm in the comments
man
hey the bunnies have taken over the
comments
the bunnies have taken keep the bunnies
going
i don't know it might be sunsets and
bunnies moving forward for the vibes
it might be the bunnies have taken over
kathy i'm just going to start giving out
hoodies you cut me off when you feel
like it
because there's a lot of bunny it's not
danny dimes you're walking away with a
hoodie shouts out to the bunnies
w.m buell you're also walking away with
a hoodie shouts out to your bunnies
jlo89 you're walking away with a hoodie
shout out to your bunnies
okay okay wait g money let's see let's
get one four three four all right that's
the last one
shout out to your buddies shout out
shout out to the buddy oh okay let me
okay let me let me get to the picks i'm
sorry
let me get there let me get there we got
the mark
219 says devonta adams
uh he got a gift he got a gift
i don't see any i see a whole bunch of
bunnies cabbie i see another devontas
jimmy sheet
says devonta uh
i got i got i got one more cheap guy 10.
once adam score you will jump like a
bunny bro
trust trust trust
trust i think i think i think i think
it's a parent
we are riding with devonta
adams to score a touchdown today i
didn't know how i felt about this one
but we do have the favorite as you can
see him
on top of the list sitting at -182 let
me show you guys a magic trick have you
guys ever seen a magic
let me show you guys something poof
hold on that didn't work let me do it
one more time oh there it is there it is
there it is don't worry do not worry do
not be afraid
the magic trick works plus 300 you see
it right there
we only can do that here us us us here
on the squad right we're the only ones
uh make sure you come on over make sure
you come on over to the instagram
uh story we'll we will be riding for
devonta adams to score a touchdown today
now listen to me here this is what i
need you guys to do
send in your videos to me greg
underscore ivory
get on the story ride with us
but remember
put it in the comments i'm giving away
hoodies
salute to our friends at draftkings for
the odds boost we appreciate that every
week and remember
tomorrow we have a special episode of
our brand new show
the br drop zone monday 6 p.m eastern
we'll have we'll be the first to drop
exclusive super bowl prop bets
and and prices from draftkings we're
going to be joined by special guests
greg's going to be giving away a ps5 you
can't get them anywhere
but we have one to give away to you and
fifteen hundred dollars of draftking
draftking bucks good luck with your
wagers wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on real quick
remember to tap into br social to get
the link
for the odds boost from draftkings greg
you were saying
[Music]
handy dandy cabbie here we go uh b
smith 34. you're walking away with a
hoodie op 19
obp 19 you're walking away with a hoodie
i got bk
riker you're walking away with a d deuce
21
last one last week you're walking away
k-pops k-pop
you're right what are you doing
dangerous that's in danger
congratulations we gotta save some for
our show tomorrow once again
it's 6 p.m eastern right here in the
bleacher report app you don't want to
miss it
we are dropped so come on come again
with uh something special or new
um good luck or thank you to all our
commenters congratulations
to all our hoodie winners there's like
400 of you guys today
and um uh thank you to our legends we
have mark marich
austin arsenault riley sorbo uh
eminem i am and louis de castro much
appreciated fellas alongside kelly
stewart and greg avery
my name is cabbie richards you've been
watching the squad ride
good luck on a championship game weekend
peace
[Music]
you